say good morning happy New Year to Kurt
Warner Kurt thanks for joining us how
are you good you as well thank you the
best coaching vacancy is where well
that's a great question I think the
bottom line is you always want to have a
quarterback and so you need look at
different spots I mean Derek Carr I
think there's a great situation there
with some some talent they were a team
that was successful a couple years ago
the harder argue with with Detroit I
think they got a lot of young pieces
some good playmakers on offense and a
quarterback as well so when I look at it
I look at the quarterback spot and those
are a couple guys that are established
anyways but some good young quarterbacks
and some other places as well yeah the
Andrew Luck situation so we don't know
if that's a good job or not because
exactly why is that such a mystery what
happened with Andrew Luck well I mean I
don't know if it's so much a mystery is
you know you're never quite sure how
people bounce back from certain injuries
and specifically when you're talking
about the right arm and you know I don't
know if it was mismanaged or it just
hasn't bounced back like they had
thought but but yeah I think anybody's
got to be a little bit leery and scary
of that scared of that situation because
man I just can't believe that it's taken
this long for him to be able to to get
back on the field you know and that's
even in practice throwing it around and
doing what you expected to do and you
know me personally not in any
information on the situation but I'm
wondering if he's going to be able to to
really come back and play at this point
yeah how important is this next game for
Blake bortles future in Jacksonville I
think it's extremely important I mean I
think they've had a great year I think
they have all the pieces there to say
man we can we can do this for a while
but it all comes down to that
quarterback position and he's got to
prove that he can consistently play at
that level and win games in the playoffs
I mean you don't want to continue to
move forward if you believe you got a
running game and a defense but not that
guy that can pull it
and win those games for you so I think
it's it's vital how he plays in the next
game or two and if he shows he can
actually win games against good teams
and good quarterbacks on the other side
yeah it's just a mystery there that he
had that run where he had seven
touchdowns no picks and then everybody
was back on board then these last couple
of games you just can't have that if
you're gonna be a consistent team
elsewhere you can't have that in an
inconsistency and it feels like he's
playing for his job every game now from
now on out in Jacksonville yeah well I
mean and you mentioned it it's all about
consistency can I expect that position
to show up weekend and week out and go
head to head with another good
quarterback if need be but not make the
mistakes that can cost our football team
and you know you continue you know like
you said he had that run and you go okay
maybe he can you know turn the corner
but in the back of everybody's mind is
still the Blake bortles that we saw
early in his career and then we've seen
it the last couple games and you know
the organization has to continue to say
you know we don't want to go into a game
wondering if that guy's going to come
out and so I think it's very important
against playoff teams to show that he
can make some plays to help them win not
just be a guy that can stand back there
and not make the mistakes to lose the
game for me can you assess a college
quarterback and have any like can you
handicap that at all playing at a high
level and being a hall-of-famer if
you're looking at these guys Baker
Mayfield or Josh Allen or Sam D'Arnot or
Josh Rosen can you look for one thing
and say that they're gonna be good in
the NFL absolutely not a couple factors
here I mean you know there's such
discrepancy at times between the college
talent for one team compared to another
team and I tweeted earlier this year
when I watched Oklahoma play it looked
like everybody was wide open you know me
and that's just not gonna happen at the
next level the guys aren't going to be
run
free wide-open you've got the spread
systems that aren't really based on
reading defenses and coverages and
having to get the ball to the right
place on time and so you don't know how
they're gonna translate there and then
the hardest thing is always the mental
part of it is I've seen quarterbacks
that were great college quarterbacks
that get to the NFL and they just can't
make those strides to get better and
better every year and then you see other
guys and you know Tom Brady is always a
great example that gets you know average
college career gets picked late in the
draft yet every year it seems like he
gets better and better and better and
you never know that until a guy gets
into that environment in that situation
and you push him and you know you give
him more and more and he plays against
the best talent and you can see that and
I think that's why it's so hard to gauge
that position and who's going to be good
and who's not because they can be great
right now but you need a guy to be even
better two years from now and even
better than that four years from now and
nobody can really gauge whether whether
a player can do that or not what
Mayfield's personality scare you or it
tracked you to him oh yeah I don't think
it would scare me away you know I think
you would have to sit down and talk to
him and you know some of the other parts
that go with the personality I'm and I
love the energy I love what you know he
brings to the table from that standpoint
I heard somebody kind of compare them to
a Brett Favre and there's those aspects
that you really love well I think
there's a there's points you got to tone
it down a little bit and still be able
to be the the face of a franchise but I
think that's about conversations and
about talking to a young kid and
figuring out whether he can mature and
develop and and understand the two sides
of that coin I'll leave you with this
there was a report Josh Rosen said that
he didn't want to be drafted by
Cleveland what do you make of that what
I make is you know on the surface you
completely understand that side of
things and go man I want to go somewhere
where I believe I can be successful and
there's a
organization hasn't for a long time but
to me the other side of it is I want to
go to Cleveland and I want to change
things if I can go to Cleveland and turn
that organization around I've done
something extremely special and
something memorable and that's how I
would look at it as a competitor but you
fully understand the other side and want
to make sure you have a chance to
succeed and they're going to give you
time and excuse me and they're gonna
keep the coach there for a period of
time and allow you to build something
and they haven't done that very well in
Cleveland so you understand the
trepidation that a guy would have in
going there and really believing they're
going to have a chance to to be a great
one current we appreciate your time good
luck this weekend
sounds good we'll talk to you soon
that's Kurt Warner and I fell Network
analyst they got games on Saturday and
Sunday and started noon eastern on
Saturday and 7:00 a.m. Eastern on Sunday
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]